alors donc moi je m'appelle
line j'ai 56 ans et j'ai du bol alors je
dire que j'ai su pour elle
que seuil est un ange qui s'est penchée
sur son berceau quand je suis né et qui
a dit toi tu auras du bol dans la vie
alors ça c'est vraiment du bol parce que
ça aurait pu être une méchante sorcière
mais non c'est pas vrai encore que
l'histoire m'amuse un peu en fait j'ai
du bol c'est c'est une décision
c'est une posture c'est une paire de
lunettes qu'on pose sur sa tête pour se
regarder pour regarder les autres pour
regarder la vie alors ça fait pas que on
n'a pas dans merde dans la vie hein ça
fait juste que on s'est un peu mieux
quoi faire avec et ça quand j'ai appris
ça quand j'ai appris que la vie ça m'a
prenait ça et ben ça me l'a rendu
vachement plus facile tant dans le
quotidien que pour piloter ma vie perso
que pour piloter ma vie pro et c'est ça
que j'aime que vous expliquer cet après
midi alors je vais vous donner quelques
exemples
le premier exemple où il va être en lien
avec la vie perso quand je savais pas
que j'avais du bol j'aurais pu vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est jeudi
et c'est le jour du pub elle et j'ai pas
envie de sortir les poubelles quand je
vais rentrer ce soir parce que ce soir
il va faire froid
il va faire nuit il va faire fatigué et
si je mets mes lunettes et que je me dis
j'ai du bol je me dis mais en fait tu as
le choix obligé de les sortir les
poubelles tapant un gendarme qui
t'attend à la maison soir avec un
pistolet pour guerlain maintenant tu
sors les poubelles jeu pour les stocker
les poubelles j'ai de la place dans ma
cuisine puis si la cuisine est rempli la
salle demain
j'ai une grande baignoire je sens bien
que ça me va pas ce truc là parce qu'on
fait ce dont j'ai besoin
j'ai besoin d'ordre j'ai besoin
d'hygiène et là pour le coup avec ma
paire de lunettes
j'ai du bol ce soir quand je vais
rentrer même s'il fait froid
une fieffée nuit même s'il fait fatigué
je les sortir mes poubelles en me disant
que j'ai du bol d'avoir des mecs qui le
lendemain matin à l'aube
on les ramasse et pour que chez moi ce
soir angers est unique
ça c'est juste le petit exemple pour la
vie quotidienne
alors cette posture là elle est aussi
super sympa dont la vie professionnelle
et ça a commencé je crois la première
fois j'étais en seconde année de dut
tech de co c'est d'être en 1984 c'est la
préhistoire pour vous un essuie un cours
d'allemand et là le prof nous 10 et 20
votre nuque du trimestre à ça va être
dans le cadre du d'animation que vous
allez mener seul ou avec un collègue
gens confient leur pendant une heure
alors la panique à bord je suis nul en
allemand mais vraiment nul en allemand
et là je me mets m.guillard wakata
qu'est ce que je vais faire c'est pas
possible je voyais arriver quoi je suis
pas capable de tenir leur correctement
en allemand et puis il ya tant
souilliart qui se met en route je sais
pas si vous le connaissez pour son égard
mais je crois qu'on est tous là dans la
tête vous savez c'est le petit hamster
qui tourne comme ça dans sa roue ah je
vois que vous aussi vous en avez un et
alors ce pan souillard là il me fait
bien sentir que ça va être le merdier
quoi et là je me dis alors je vais
mettre ma perte du net j'ai du bol puis
je regarde autour de moi puis je vois
pierre dans ma classe alors pierre et
moi on se connaît pas beaucoup parce que
on y serait différent on n'a pas les
mêmes attend crochet ou brunes pas
ensemble soir 1
et puis je vois que pierre luc aimé
gabon en allemand il fait la gueule
aussi quoi donc je dois répudie attend
pierre pour que tu fais là tu es tu toi
tu maîtrises médias bien l'allemand il
dit ouais je maîtrisais mégabits en
allemand mais par contre l'animation je
maîtrise pas quoi et là je me dis moi je
maîtrise bien l'animation rouge maîtrise
pas l'allemand mais je veux tu respires
l'animation et du coup on décide qu'on
va faire un truc ensemble
donc concrètement j'écris une pièce de
théâtre en français il l'a traduit en
allemand
on l'apprend par coeur je fais la mise
en scène en et 18 et au passage j'ai
jamais autant appris l'allemand avec
bonheur conduit dans cette expérience là
et là j'apprends un truc
j'apprends qu'on a tous des talents et
que quand on les compile ses talents on
fait des trucs super et donc ça je
développe au fur et à mesure où fur et à
mesure devant parcours et à force de le
faire je le fais de mieux en mieux et je
le fais tellement que de mieux en mieux
qu'aujourd'hui c'est mon boulot c'est à
dire qu'en fait mon job aujourd'hui
c'est d'être consultante
donc je vais dans des entreprises et
puis je vais dire aux gens vous avez des
talents et tous vos talons compilés ça
va permettre de produire qu'est ce que
ce quelque chose de chouette pour demain
pour vous pour votre boîte et ça marche
parce que quand on dit aux gens vous
êtes talentueux règle générale il aime
bien et du coup ils participent quoi
l'autre point c'est que vu de ce point
de vue là j'ai piloté ma vie comme ça
c'est à dire que chaque fois qu'il
m'arrive un truc ya 20 ans ou yark et
peut se mettre en route où je peux
décider que j'ai du bol
je vous donne un autre exemple 1992 je
travaille dans l'entreprise familiale
j'ai 30 ans mon projet il est tout tracé
je vais reprendre la boîte et en plus
c'est le pied 1 30 ans j'étais gosse je
peux m'organiser comme je veux
l'activité ne passionne pas cette
l'électricité et l'électricité ces
points de mes talons mais par contre
reprendre une boîte saint-branchs
embarquer des gens dans l'aventuré en
branches et 92 c'est les jeux à
albertville et 92 ça va c'est 93 qui va
moins bien parce que 93 il ya plus de
budget et quand il ya plus de budget n'y
a plus de boulot
et quand il ya plus de boulot il ya dix
ans iman économique donc licenciement
économique le projet prouve par terre
donc bon soir se met en route quand même
pas normal parce que moi j'ai vraiment
faire mieux que je peux dans mon job est
ok et puis du coup je mets ma paire de
lunettes j'ai du bol et je me dis alors
comment j'ai du bol avec ce truc là quoi
et là pour le coup je me dis mais
peut-être que c'est l'occase de créer un
projet qui est encore plus chouette que
ce que lui
ce que celui que j'avais avant et donc
j'ouvre grand mes yeux j'ouvre grand mes
oreilles et je regarde ce qui se passe
dans le monde et je suis accueillie dans
le cadre d'une convention de conversion
où il ya un type qui nous reçoit épi qui
nous dit eh ben voilà vous avez tous des
talents et puis on va
vous aider à les voir et puis à savoir
quoi faire avec
pour rendre ce monde plus chouette et
notamment dans le cadre de du
professionnel et je regarde ce type et
je me dis mais attends c'est génial son
boulot à lui puis alors en plus ça me
parle quoi puis sacko la mildt allons du
coup je vais le voir puis je lui dis et
je suis dit si vous avez besoin de
quelqu'un faites moi signe quoi je vois
du tout la formation qui va avec
et puis il y un mois et il m'en bouche
et je fais disons comme ça à apprendre à
accompagner les gens pour les aider à
aller vers quelque chose de plus
chouette pour eux
vous savez pas à quel point ça procure
plein de bonheur et la vie fait que dix
ans après je crée ma brouette donc
aujourd'hui j'ai ma boîte je fais un
truc que j'aime
et puis et puis non seulement je fais un
truc que j'aime dans les organisations
et dans les entreprises parce que c'est
plutôt cool de dire que on a filé un
petit coup de main pour aider à ce que
les choses aillent mieux et que chacun
se sont mieux dans sa vie
professionnelle mais en plus comme j'ai
appris à faire tout ça est que assez des
talents que j'ai développé et bien j'ai
développé aussi une activité de
thérapeutes
je suis le des coups de main à des
individus qui viennent me voir pour
faire en sorte que la vie à mieux sur le
plan perso alors ces postures là je
redis c'est une décision
c'est une posture c'est une paire de
lunettes
quoi qu'il se passe dans la vie quand on
se dit ok j'ai du bol en quoi j'ai du
bol là avec ce qui m'arrive même si ce
qui m'arrive c'est pas rigolo ça empêche
pas que c'est pas toujours simple mais
par contre ça ouvre plein de
perspectives et ça donne le choix et ça
c'est vraiment génial
alors pour le coup et je crois que pour
illustrer ce point de vue l'aise que je
pourrais dire aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est que je viens de passer quelques
minutes avec vous à faire un truc que
j'aime particulièrement
c'est transmettre ce à quoi je crois et
qui plus est devant un auditoire de gens
qui sont pétris de talent et en plus
aujourd'hui c'est jeudi
et c'est le jour des poubelles alors
j'ai du bol ou pas merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]